good afternoon everybody I'm important
the Andrew W Mellon director of the New
York Public Library and I'm really
excited to be here this afternoon with
such a great panel of folks and let me
make some quick introductions to you to
them although they don't really need an
introduction Josh greenberg is director
of the Alfred P sloan foundations
digital information technology program
mara marks is deputy director of the
Office of library services at IMLS
currently serving as the acting director
of the Institute of Museum and Library
Services and Don waters is the Senior
Program Officer for scholarly
communications at the Andrew W mellon
Foundation and we convened via phone to
talk about what this session what we
wanted to bring out in this session with
all of you and engage you all thinking
about we also talked about what this
session isn't and so I thought I'd start
by saying what it isn't it isn't going
to give you a five-point plan for
getting money out of Josh Mara or dawn
but you're all still sitting here and
that tells me that you are interested in
what they have to say and I think that
what is particularly valuable about
their perspectives is that they spend a
lot of time in conversation and
discussion and listening with folks who
are thinking about the big shifts the
kinds of shifts that we've been talking
about this morning and hearing about
this morning but in a landscape that is
inclusive of libraries but is not
exclusively about libraries and library
service and so that's where we're going
to start today and i'm going to ask Don
waters to kick us off to share some of
the bigger shifts that he is observing
in the broader landscape that includes
libraries thanks a lot in on somebody
hopefully suggested that we all leave
hundred-dollar bills at the door but
we're not doing that either and as an
said I think it's quite true that what
we learn and what I have what we all
have to say collectively is really what
we've learned from our constituents the
you in this room others in libraries and
museums and related institutions around
the country and in some cases around the
world um I think it's hard to beat the
list the comprehensive list that Jim
gave this morning of you know high
priority questions that need to be
addressed on jim has keeps us his own
finger on the pulse of these issues and
is usually very accurate if
overwhelmingly accurate in some cases
because it such a long list and the
issues that I will raise now are really
a result of the listening that we've
been doing at mellon and in conjunction
with a planning process that we've under
taken over the last couple of years with
our new president and that has resulted
in a sort of focus on some of the things
because we could do a lie and even
though we have fantastic resources we
can't do everything and so that the
narrowing has been that we've agreed
within the foundation at least for
scholarly communications purposes to
focus on of the potential of the digital
technologies to expand and equalize
access to cultural and scholarly
resources and that's across all sectors
and i'll come back to the diversity
question that was raised earlier at the
end and i in in the spirit of jim's list
i'll have I have just five points that I
want to draw your attention to first is
national infrastructure and an area that
we have been focusing on and I know that
my colleagues at Sloan and I MLS have
also been focusing on is areas where
there are the potential to develop
national infrastructure for digital
materials for education and research the
digital Public Library of America comes
to mind as rated top of that list the
clear initiative on coherence at scale
on I think you need to dig a little bit
to understand the definition of
coherence it's an you know kind of an
odd phrase in in our in our world but
the intention of trying to bring
together and I'll just pick out the
example of the proliferation of
preservation organizations that have
occurred over the last four or five
years since to cohere them into a a more
understandable on array of organizations
would be hugely helpful and then a third
area I'll just mentioned briefly is the
so called collective collection how we
are dealing with our print collections
collectively across the nation
and there is and has been over the last
decade or so a growing interest among
libraries in how to do that how to do it
well and we have a proposal on the table
right now that's looking at an issue
that I don't think really has been
addressed and that's the issue of
verification if you are retaining these
items how do you know that it's actually
on the shelf and it's not a question
that many libraries want to face up to I
don't imagine that there are many that
are on the shelf but we just don't know
and it's an important question second
area is and I'm just going to briefly
mention this is digital publishing we've
invested over the last year an enormous
effort at the foundation to learn from
faculty from administrators from
libraries presses around the country and
I was on the road quite a bit last year
in this initiative to figure out how we
can enhance the quality of digital
publication and think of the minimal
quality right now that you get out of a
PDF and what it could be and what how
you can get there and we're focused
particularly on the monographs and how
that needs to migrate in the digital
digital world and we've made about 15 or
16 grants in the last two cycles of on
this area and the one of the biggest
areas is addressing the need for faculty
to be able to publish works that they
can't publish in print based on their
work in the digital environment how they
refer to sources how they refer to other
related work online and the skills that
are needed to write in that environment
the apparatus on annotation and so on
that is needed to produce a quality work
a third area that I'd highlight I think
Jim also mentioned this morning and
that's the area of linked data there is
a number there this is this is an area
of technology that's been around
were a couple of decades and it's only
recently I and in my view it's got an
enormous amount of traction there are a
lot of projects that output link data
now and not much effort to aggregate
that metoo that those linked data and
show what the links do how they make the
world better but the the promise is that
we will move away from standards and
especially if we adopt this in our
library processing we move out of the
world of library centric inward-looking
types of systems and play in the network
and I think that's the real promise and
I know some of the staff here at
Columbia are at a meeting at LC today to
discuss ways of integrating linked data
processing in the library environment I
will issue one quick warning on that um
that there is no ultimate salvation here
the re-emergence of the metadata wars
are likely to occur and they already are
occurring on you have see doc or CRM you
have a schema.org and you have bid frame
and they are all competing with one
another and of course the promise is
that we'll just do crosswalks out in the
world will be lovely but I'm not sure
that that's going to work out exactly
that way um fourth area that I mentioned
is a complicated area in a world where
we are so intent on open access and I
will put it this way where we need to be
looking at how to deal with restrictions
in an open environment this is an area
that we had figured out in the analog
environment we have reading rooms where
there's ways and procedures in which we
can address the issue of privacy private
data in electric the material it's
protected by intellectual property
ethical issues having to do sacred
materials from
tribal societies and so on and we don't
have comparable mechanisms in the
digital environment to deal with that
and to deal with it in a way that
promotes access to that material and
doesn't just hide it away and there are
identity management issues here most of
the campuses in the US have been working
with Internet to to build these trust
networks and identity management systems
but I'll bet most of the people in this
room do not even know who the person is
on your campus that's responsible for
that and it's it's a world that needs to
be brought into the library and put in
the sandbox experimented with so that we
learn how to administer restrictive
access to restricted material using
tools that allow certain kinds of people
to use the material and we've got a long
way to go there it opens the door for
what I think Susan Gibbons coined as the
virtual reading room and I and we we
really need to be moving in that
direction a last area i mentioned has to
do with preservation and it has multiple
dimensions here i mentioned the
collective collection as we aggregate
these material in these collections we
need more than ever to ensure that we
have expertise for conservation to
conserve those materials and that is the
conservation of afraid as a dying art
and we don't have good training programs
in the country for for this skill um
we've made some progress in journals in
preserving published journals but not a
lot that's the Cornell Columbia
collaboration has shown that we need we
have a far way to go there but the web
is still in many ways virgin territory
and even more virgin than that is the
area of software and most of the what's
interesting is that our ability to
preserve the web depends on our ability
to deal with software because a lot of
the
web things we're trying to capture run
on software i do want to mention in
closing the diversity question and I
think this is an area that we have it's
an area that the foundation has been
concerned about for a long time in
general and higher education and it's an
area that all the programs now are
taking a much closer look at we've
started commissioning studies in a
couple of our programs and it's an area
that we're underrepresented on people in
this country need to be brought into the
mainstream of higher education research
libraries museums archives and so on and
it's underrepresented in multiple
dimensions how many of you have been in
a technology meeting where there's been
more than one or two women and we need
to focus specifically on the ethnic and
racial divide in in our world as well I
can't say at this point what our ways of
addressing this are we've made a couple
of initiatives in my program but we have
a long way to go and that's going to be
another area of focus Thank You Don Josh
you want to jump in neck shirt um was
this can you hear me okay so I had
figured I would just spend a minute or
two looking forward to the discussion
just giving a sense of how I'm looking
at the world and what I'm what I'm
seeing as you know in some sense maybe
not at the level of the items on the
tablet but just the tablet itself so my
program at the sloan foundation is is
really fundamentally focused on enabling
scholarship particularly in the natural
and Social Sciences as the main area
that Sloan funds but I also came out of
a digital humanities background before
that and so I'm really interested in
scholarship broadly in a changing
technological context and what I mean by
that is is first and foremost the
ability to generate and access sort of
data at vastly greater scale than than
before and I mean data in a very generic
sense the need to apply computational
approaches to that data in order to
distill knowledge out of it and the
ability to collaborate
and share over digital networks I'm a
historian of technology by training I'm
very aware that we're still in the very
early days of understanding these
technologies it's not that you know
before the past decade or a couple
decades you know researchers didn't work
with data that wasn't the case at all
but there's a there's a difference in
character of and scale of what we're
seeing over the past over the past year
you can choose your threshold but but
well at least say once people started
talking about big data and we can if you
want unpack why that term makes me very
uncomfortable so in the context of that
broad interest I've spent a lot of time
working with libraries funding libraries
but doing them and I think it's an
important point not as a not as ends in
themselves but as means as as important
and essential parts of the research
ecosystem but with an eye towards that
that broader agenda of facilitating
scholarship and and the reason that I
that I that I frame it that way is is to
take an example to over the past handful
of years data has sucked a ton of air
out of the room you know everybody here
probably in some way or another is
trying to figure you know it wasn't just
that the NSF lit a fire under research
data management and everybody had to
figure out how to deal with it but that
that was an important sort of trigger
it's not purely on one end of the
Disciplinary spectrum really on all
sides there's there's this issue of
research data that seems very squarely
on the agenda and so when I came into
Sloan almost five years ago now that was
clearly the first topic to engage and
you know we did a number of things
ranging from supporting the data
management plan tool on the sort of like
technology side of the spectrum to you
know helping to support the the clear
dlf data curation postdocs on the sort
of you know workforce side and
understanding the relationships between
these different strategies but what I've
come to realize what I've come to really
really see clearly over the past couple
years to pick up on one of the last
points dawn made is that if you tug the
thread of data hard enough you realize
the data in itself is actually pretty
inert data is a thing and if you want to
understand how to support the production
and you know extension and
dissemination of scholarship you tuck on
that threat of data inevitably it leads
you to software because you in this era
you don't operate on data by looking at
it and taking out a pencil and you know
you're operating on it with code those
are the tools of 20th 21st century data
driven research regardless of whether
it's it's it's in in sort of
microbiology or economics or you know
distant reading of literature so once
you get to software you realize that you
know if the library has a role in
stewarding products of research you're
you know inevitably I think more and
more we're going to be getting to how do
you how do you save software how do you
preserve it how do you manage it both so
that it's an object for future use but
also so that so that if you want to pick
up a study and extend it you have that
material to work with and I think
there's a really important point in this
which which is the one thing that i want
to say here but you know to start a
discussion which is I think this
positions libraries in a different way
with regard to the research process that
you know it's not and there isn't the
sort of strong main character that
libraries always just preserve the
output of the research process libraries
have been an integral part of research
from the very early stages of a resource
process all the way through but often in
a discovery or in a you know there's a
getting people to material and then and
at least and I would welcome challenges
to this but my sense from working in
libraries and and working as a scholar
in libraries is that there's been a
hesitancy to over determine the research
itself that there's a sense of a
partnership there's a sense of a but a
sort of you know a sense of a boundary
and once you start thinking about
preserving software preserving the
actual context of research itself and
you start to I hear this partly in the
way that the word curation is deployed
partly in the cotton in the context of
data we're starting to hear this in the
context of software curation is a much
more active role than then then
preservation and I think there may be
something interesting to play with in
even the way that those terms are are
used so from where I sit you know
sitting up on the 22nd floor of
of one of the buildings at Rockefeller
Center trying to understand how a place
like Sloan can can help contribute using
the you know I always say this and it
gets chuckles but using frankly the
relatively limited means that that we
have at our disposal you know it becomes
a question of how to library how to help
libraries engage in these different ways
in research processes how to help them
build different kinds of relationships
with researchers where there's a more
where there's it where there isn't a
sort of a transactional character to it
but a collaborative one one of the
things that that I've found really
interesting in the work around data
science which is this really interesting
category that I know is very you know is
a very important topic of interest here
at Columbia and elsewhere is it really
is unclear right now what's a the
library's role in facilitating data
science research is and I think there's
an opportunity there to help shape norms
and 22 model particularly some some more
sort of upstream collaborative processes
so I'll leave it with that and you know
we can pick up threads and discussion
Thank You Mara great to go last
especially after Jim's wonderful
introduction this morning and then my
fellow panelists we're a little
different you know where the federal
funding agency so we fund all types of
libraries we're not just focused on
research library at the academy so I
won't rehash you know a lot of the
things they you've said are of
importance to us too but some other
things as well and we've changed the way
that sort of the mechanism for funding
to try to bring in the community to
guide us in national priorities because
you know Don talked about a focus we
have limited dollars we have a large
amount of money that goes out and
programmatic funding all across the
country and then we have limited
discretionary dollars that we really
have to focus on things that we can try
to shift and so we look to you for input
we also recently raised the bar on the
level of our funding so that the Academy
would come back to us because we're a
while we had lowered that fresh hole
then we weren't seeing your involvement
in what we do so that's important to us
and I'll just do the plug we're having a
series of convenings this spring so
please speak up during those that's
where we get a lot of our priorities I
was just looking at the notes that I
took you know infrastructure yes you
know the infrastructure that the Academy
has and has built over the last decades
we look out we made a huge investment in
that we also invest in state
infrastructure and they are the largest
recipients the state library
administrative agencies are the largest
recipients of funding through LSTA
they're also starting to grapple with
the data issue so I think they're
looking for ways to work with partners
who have experience so I think we look
at our role as trying to bring together
these different parties where there
could be synergy there could be that
kind of radical collaboration that never
existed in the past between state
libraries are you know city public
libraries and the Academy on
infrastructure so we think about that a
lot data data what more can I say data
management plans are part of what we
judge grants on these days we look at
that people are getting savvy about
those plans they're looking at the life
cycle after the end of the grant you
know the data management plan has to go
on way after the grant itself has ended
so that's something that our reviewers
thankfully are savvy about and are
helping us to look at enough said we're
also looking at community involvement in
participation you know as part of all of
these efforts who is a good citizen who
who is at the at the agency people talk
about the twenty-thousand-dollar
question that there's all these things
that you know we can solve this problem
if you just pay twenty thousand dollars
a year and the thing will keep running
so how many of those
twenty-thousand-dollar things are being
supported how do you decide which things
are the ones to support what what do you
look for in sustainability how long
should those things
be expected to live and to function
those are the types of things that we're
thinking about what else the development
of the profession has been talked about
a lot today we've shifted the way that
we fund that too I think in the past we
funded a lot of maybe doctoral student
not a lot of very few actually a couple
of doctoral students to go through
programs now we're looking at how can we
maximize the use of those dollars and do
things like the National Digital
stewardship I can't even say the program
at so many words but residency's where
we you know these are programs where
young professionals are taking given
some training and then planted into host
organizations where they learn and
practice data curation you know that
type of thing is something that we want
to do more of because we think that and
by the way as I'm saying that they don't
always have to be young you know we're
interested in taking people and helping
to train them in all those ways no I
mean that was a good comment that was
made earlier today so diversity we
support you and we want to support more
you know we look around too and we see
that as still a problem and we're always
looking and open two ways to bring just
more more people from different
backgrounds into the into the profession
two things that don't have to do with
the Academy hands-on in participatory
learning we think about this a lot
because we support a lot of public
libraries we like to think there's this
great big cycle where all those kids who
are playing in the library today are
going to come and staff the academic
library of the future and so we're
trying to make that experience as much
about again self-driven learning what
are you interested in the library will
support it in all kinds of ways we are
there to facilitate learning in all ways
so that's just one more trend I think
that's important and finally Jim's words
on information policy you know the role
of one of the roles of IMLS is to advise
the President on
matters of policy related to libraries
so we do look for strong voices in the
community who can help us think through
some of the biggest issues of the time
you know we're all worried about
copyright but what what else and what
are we doing what are the actions so I
think that's an overview let's get two
questions great conversation before we
get to some questions I just want to
follow up with a question about the big
shifts that you've identified the
changes and the implications and
opportunities for libraries what are
some of the what is how does the
particular identity of the library
within institutions in academia and the
core values of libraries that we heard
spoken about this morning how did those
play a positive role in dealing with
some of the issues and shifts that
you've raised Josh you talked about
curation and you know libraries have a
commitment to that and to content and
context and so forth but what are some
of the other things i can throw one
other one out that doesn't necessarily
directly flow from what i said but one
of the one of the touchstones I keep
coming back to and my work I spend a lot
of time trying to think about how to
avoid the same wheel getting reinvented
in various disciplines because there can
be very high walls very high silos
between between various academic
disciplines and and from where I sit at
a you know in the role that I'm in
libraries are are one of the very few
and arguably the best position trading
zone between disciplines and I use the
word trading zone particularly again so
the historian of science Peter Gallison
sort of appropriated the term trading
zone out of out of the anthropological
literature to talk about point spaces
between disciplines places where things
like pigeon languages or or you know
common modes of exchange can can help to
facilitate cultural cross cross
pollination and shared production and
and again thinking sort of in aggregate
the way knowledge is made today and the
various systems of professions and
disciplines I think there's a tremendous
role for the library which is sort of
geographically and philosophically at
the heart of the University in being an
open space so the openness inclusiveness
service to all comers that that norm is
something we don't often talk about as
much as commitment to privacy or or etc
and I think you know there's a desperate
need in the modern University in the
modern sort of knowledge landscape for
libraries to really embrace that role
donmar I anything to add on that use
just thinking of that in terms of cities
again because we found all types of
libraries so we think about that in
terms of how a library relates to all of
the different institutions in a city and
can bring all of those together we we're
encouraged libraries to be much more
engaged to go outside their walls to
bring institutions together so yeah
right okay let's get to some questions
um so we'll have our microphone asst
vanda we can keep talking amongst
ourselves up here if you'd rather but
it's more fun if you talk to us and with
absolutely so following up on some of
the things that Don was saying idea of
coherence in digital preservation it's a
very important one to work toward
because they're all of these initiatives
going on not really talking to each
other and I think it would be really
great to have sort of national
discussion about how to move forward in
these the next thing is that in fact the
concept of a trusted digital repository
that we've been hanging on to for a
while I think I'm interested in when you
know how you all are viewing that now
and whether there's any help that you
can give us and actually keeping that
concept alive in face of Amazon you know
glacier and things like that and then
finally I guess the storage question I'm
interested in to see how whether you
have leadership that you could give us
or opportunities you could give us to
think about this gigantic expensive need
that underlies all digital preservation
that many
not well funded for good to see you
thanks for that no I don't think I can
elaborate more on the coherence question
except to say that clearer has sort of
taken on that problem and has got a
national looking at it whether and part
of our funding was to act for them to
develop a strategic plan so that it it
goes beyond that committee that group of
thinkers on the the the questions about
repositories that Jim erased it this
morning that there's a proliferation of
types and kinds of repositories and
there isn't a lot of coherence in that
there's a lot of proliferation of them
certainly diversity is a good thing in
some ways and in other ways it becomes a
a burden to have you know flowers
blooming all over the place and not have
ways of differentiating them and
aggregating material from them so that
people can find and so on and our
funding ended in this area with the
development of fedora and D space so we
created the tools and now I think we
need certainly as a funding agency we
would need to hear more about way some
ideas about how to bring those into
greater coherence does every institution
need one can there be more shared back
backroom kinds of activities to share
those repositories you know hide the you
know what wait label the front end for
the institution but actually be using
shared repositories in the back
background I think some of that work is
going on in the press community where
they are facing exactly the same problem
and in some ways on a smaller scale that
if you're going to produce digital
monographs for for example they're going
to live online they need
not every press wants to build its own
repository so they're struggling with
that question now too and I think your
third question about storage relates
directly to that about ways in which you
can collaborate to produce efficiencies
and I we don't haven't given a whole lot
of thought to any of those questions at
this point I think let me let me jump in
I've at least two thoughts though
definitely no answers so sorry the UM so
so first the on the on the question of
sort of you know you mentioned amazon
glacier things like that we spend a lot
of time around the foundation talking
about where are things coming out of the
market anyways where are there things
that that aren't and and where
philanthropic funds particularly need to
be focused in order to help to support
the the creation of of public goods of
services that will sort of be a value
broadly that's that's really how we
understand and internally talk about our
work so so on one hand at least for my
own experience what i found is that line
has shifted even over the past handful
of years and I I again can't offer you
no particular guidance but to say that
it's a challenge we're facing to
understanding as industry moves very
quickly and races ahead understanding
when to cut off lines of funding when to
when to shift to other priorities but
also understanding how to how to
maintain sort of safety nets underneath
you know and not overly trust say
industry solutions even if you know the
herd is so big and moving in such a
coherent direction that it's
unfathomable that that those solutions
could could just fundamentally you know
be yanked away one day on your point
about about funding for storage the only
thing that I that I dad to Don's
response is is it strikes me that
there's a particular problem right now
which is the consumers of those of that
storage are pretty strongly insulated
from the costs of that storage when
provisioned by particularly when
provision by by libraries I mean this is
a structural problem in libraries and a
number of and and um you know we've seen
this and say you know subscription
litter
turin and i think you know one of the
interesting challenges is to figure out
how to how to how to think about making
those costs and and and and trade-offs
more tangible because it seems like
libraries are in a really tough
situation if they're the sort of
universal provisioner of services and
and and goods but um but then have to
figure out you know without the patrons
without the the researchers knowing how
this all actually gets paid for agency
problems and exactly yeah um I'm asking
a question that may have an answer in
this room it may not I work in
electronic reserves I've been doing that
for ten years and one thing I think
would benefit from funding and through
collaborative efforts of course would be
standardization of certain aspects of
what I do for example persistent links
direct object indicators some initiative
perhaps that if funded would ensure that
it would be adopted across the board
internationally there have been some
mentioned earlier scholarship and not
being able to get to information because
links have disappeared the link rot and
then I think of other times other
anecdotes where say a publisher such as
Hayworth gets acquired by someone else
and then all of their documents are
inaccessible and then we have public
domain websites for example government
NGOs and such that publish white papers
and such and those disappear of course
we have the internet our internet
archive but shouldn't we be spending
more on making sure ensuring that what
we have now not simply institutional
repositories but the actual work that is
available through peer reviewed or
through professional organization
be protected I am constantly renewing
and refreshing links there are only two
years old this is a great question and
you know of course the good thing about
standards is that there's so many of
them and that's part of the problem the
what i would i would suggest though is
that this is partly a a policy question
and it's a big part of it is policy and
you know having simple things like
oversight over the change of websites
when you know the redesigned and and
moved to a different platform paying
attention to your own links and how they
are migrated to the new platform is
something and i know this is true from
the the change we just made at mellon it
was the last thing on the list and it
can't be she's telling us know if
there's one minute wrap it up though I
guess we're wrapping so there's been a
lot of lot of recent discussion because
of work at Carnegie Mellon on the issue
of what they call execute o executable
content that being a if a program or an
application is developed with a
particular software should a individual
who comes later to use that application
expect to be able to look at it in the
context in which it was developed that
is the same software or are we going to
expect over time that new software will
be written to allow those data to be
looked at in the old ways as well as new
new ways so I wonder if you reflect very
briefly on the whole arena of executable
content and is it is it is it a niche
issue or is it something which is
increasingly important I can I mean I
can start with that so from my work at
Sloan my sort of i'm interested in this
for a bunch of different reasons but my
sort of primary move into that that area
is from looking at what the researchers
we're serving and trying to help are
doing today and how they're doing their
work and in fact in your in the way you
framed it i think you know i worry about
sort of even a step further where you
know you look at what a bioinformatics
researcher does today she doesn't have
just one application that she uses you
know scientific workflows are chained
together sequences of everything from
small command-line scripts up through up
to sort of very substantial
bioinformatics pipelines to
visualization software to other things
and if you want to actually be able to
understand we just review much less sort
of extend that work you you can't just
freeze these things in amber and treat
them as documents you have to treat them
as environments and you have to you have
to be able to do that accordingly now
that's incredibly hard and frankly also
this is sort of what I was trying to get
out before that requires a foothold up
into the research process that isn't
just about outputs or products that
requires being able to to not just have
agency with regard to the researchers
with regard to the environments that in
which they work to be able to do that
curation and that promote preservation
upstream so so so yeah that's really the
the issue to me and and I think there
are also a lot of other you know frankly
as more and more of our culture exists
in mediated by by software in one way or
another I worry about not maintaining
those those those systems but yeah
really first and foremost given my sort
of primary program at Sloan right now
it's it's the research context let me
see well they're just a very brief we
had our convening last year on the
National digital platform our funding
priority and one of the most important
questions I think that was asked there
was okay so where does the library
platform if we can even agree that we
share a national digital library
platform to start to bring coherence to
many of these efforts that have been
funded over the last 30 years where do
we come up against or in mesh with the
commercial platforms and other platforms
that
stout there and that's a an example of
one of those instances there are many
more in response I would make two points
one I pick up on what Josh just said
which i think is a huge point and that
is and our awareness of this problem
will grow as scholars become more aware
of the issue in their own peer review
yes and I think that's true in a
humanities publication as well they've
some of the projects we've just funded
on embed a technical peer review in the
review of a digital project that needs
to be published and that that review
itself has to take account of okay what
happens 20 years from now when we try to
read that book and so that's the first
point in the second point is that and I
think you all appreciate this because
you often call for foundations to
collaborate with one another the three
of us have been working exactly on this
problem after Vint Cerf made his
beautiful talk at the triple-a s and
mentioned the olive project on we have
been talking about how to advance that
and what we've done collectively is to
commission a review of and its olive
project at Carnegie Mellon isn't the
only one there are several others
Internet Archive there's a project in
Germany and so on looking at emulations
as a solution and we have a reviewer of
those projects to carefully examine what
the state of the art in computer
engineering is in regards to this
process and what the applications are
how we can advance it to a production
stage and so maybe we should end on that
Ohio
you